(inspiring music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape,
bipedal, naked, large brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism,
we grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here,
an exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
(ethereal music)
(upbeat music)
- I'm gonna give you a little
bit of a break from the brain
and focus on the face.
So, a central, if in fact
not the central question
in modern biology is to understand
the genotype to phenotype connection.
In other words, how does information
encoded by the genome reveals itself
through the developmental process
to produce specific phenotypes?
And, the flip side to this question
is to understand how
variation between the genome,
during evolution produces
phenotypic variation,
either between species,
or between individuals
within the same species.
And, how come such common genetic variants
can determine disease susceptibility
in complex human diseases.
I'm sure most of you heard by now
that most complex disease
and trait associated variants
not to the noncoding part of the genome.
So not to our genes per se,
the protein coding parts of the genome,
but to the vast noncoding space
that comprises over 98
percent of the genome.
Moreover, evidence begins to emerge
that these variants are enriched
within cis-regulatory elements,
and especially within a specific class
of regulatory elements called enhancers.
So these are modular genetic sequences
that can activate gene
expression at large distances,
and are typically specialized
to activate gene expression
in a specific tissue context.
And the idea here, is that
this genetic variance,
or single nucleotide
polymorphisms within enhancers,
can produce either weak or
strong enhancer alleles,
which in turn, can lead to
quantitative differences
in gene expression and
influence downstream traits.
We learned from the evo-devo community
working on model organisms
that starting this regulatory
landscape evolution
of closely related species
can be an extremely powerful tool
in uncovering genotype
to phenotype connections.
So for example, elegant
work from Sean Carroll,
David Kingsley, and others,
unequivocally demonstrated
the change in enhancer sequence
can dictate change in phenotypes,
such as wing pattern in Drosophila,
or skeletal changes in stickleback fish.
And we were very interested
in extending this type
of evo-devo thinking
into humans and other primates.
But of course, as it's
already been mentioned,
some of the key developmentally
and evolutionary important cell types
cannot be studied directly
in embryonic context
from humans and other great apes,
for obvious ethical reasons,
but it has already been introduced,
that now with induced
pluripotent stem cell models,
we can study cellular
and molecular mechanisms
underlying phenotypic
divergence in high primates.
And a few years back, we referred
to this general strategy
as cellular anthropology.
So one of the phenotypes that
we are most interested in,
is human face and also human
craniofacial development.
We know that craniofacial variation,
both within and between species,
is largely genetically encoded.
So we have unique facial features
that are distinct from
those of other great apes,
but also there is a lot
of individual variation in facial form,
both within the humans
but also in our close
evolutionary relatives.
So the question is,
what are the cellular
origins of facial variation?
Well, it turns out that
most of our face and head
is derived from the single cell type
called cranial neural crest cells.
These are very unique
cells that form early
in gestations of three to five weeks.
They're induced in dorsal
anterior part of the neural tube,
and then they migrate long distances.
And their destination,
they can differentiate to a
large variety of cell types,
including bone, cartilage,
connective tissue,
cranial nerve, and pigment cells.
And as a result, in fact,
most of the craniofacial complex
is derived from the neural crest.
Moreover, seminal work
from Nicole Le Douarin,
and others showed
through cross species
transplantation experiments
in avian embryos, that these cells
autonomously carry much of the information
on species specific facial morphology.
So these cells are important,
but how can we access them
from humans and other primates?
As you already probably realized,
this is a tricky proposition.
So, this is transient embryonic cell types
forming at three to
five weeks of gestation.
We cannot access them
directly from the embryo,
but thanks to the IPS and ES technologies,
we can derive them in vitro,
and indeed that's what my lab has done
over the last several years
is establish protocols
to obtain in vitro cells
with bonafide characteristics
of the cranial neural crest cells.
More recently, Sara Prescott,
a former graduate student in the lab,
working in collaboration with Rusty Gage,
extended this model to our chimpanzee.
And here, really a few key features were,
to reduce heterogeneity of the population
and properly stage human and chimp cells,
because unless you do that,
the developmental differences
are gonna dominate
over species differences.
And moreover, we also
went to great lengths
so I'm sure that not only
molecular signatures,
but also cellular
properties of these cells
represent bona fide neural crest cells.
So for example, we can
transplant these cells,
through the chick embryo neural tube,
and they will then engraft, migrate,
and assume correct positional
identities in the embryo.
And they also retain
this very broad differentiation potential,
characteristic of the crest.
So now with this model in hand,
we use epigenomic strategy
to systematically annotate
regulatory elements.
So just to give you an idea,
for those of you who are not
so familiar with epigenomics,
when active enhancers share
certain common chromatin features.
And when we can use
technology, like ChIP-seq
or ATAC-seq to map these
features genome wide
in an unbiased manner
in a specific cell type.
And then, we can correlate these changes
in epigenomic patterns
with changes in gene expression
determined by RNA-seq.
So to do this, Sara took
neural crest cells in vitro,
derived neural crest cells
from multiple, independent
chimp and human individuals
and performed mapping
of transcription factors
and general coactivators,
analysis of hypersensitivity by ATAC-seq,
and also analyzed certain chemical tags,
or histone modifications that
are present on nucleosomes
when regulatory elements are active.
And based on the simple
chromatin signatures,
she was able to map enhancers
that are active in the neural crest cells
and also distinguish them
from other classes of regulatory elements,
such as promoters, and
then ultimately linked
to differences in gene expression.
One thing that I really need to mention,
is that not only we can map
these regulatory elements,
but that quantitative comparisons
of chromatin signatures of these elements,
can be used to infer
differences in their activity.
So, it's not only where
these enhancers are,
but we can compare quantitatively
these tags, chromatin signatures
to infer how different they are
in their activity between the species.
So this forms the basis of what I refer to
as comparative epigenomics.
And the idea here is simple,
that we're comparing, in the same cell,
that between two closely related species.
So, most of these epigenomic
patterns that we recover
should be invariant
between the two species,
but the idea is also that
we will be able to see
some differences,
quantitative differences,
in those chemical tags
that mark active chromatin,
which will be indicative of the difference
in regulatory activity,
which then hopefully
we'll also be able to link
to differences in gene expressions.
So, that's the idea.
How does the actual data look like?
Well indeed, most of
the epigenomic patterns
are invariant between human and chimp,
but we also see, at the subset of,
smaller subset of regions
we see differences,
as indicted here in this
chimp biased region,
or indicated here at this
human biased enhancer region.
So we can quantify
them, these differences,
across the whole genome
and compare different
individuals of the same species.
So, different humans or different chimps,
and that variation is shown here in red.
Or, we can compare between the species,
between human and chimp.
And as you can see,
there's more variation
between the species,
shown here in blue than
within the species.
And we will refer to those falling outside
as either human-biased
or chimp-biased candidate
enhancer regions.
Importantly, we can also
see these regulatory changes
with changes in gene expression.
So in other words, genes
near human-biased enhancers
tend to be human-biased in expression,
and those near chimp-biased enhancers
are chimp-biased in expression.
And that's of course important,
because it's gene expression difference
that ultimately matters for
exerting phenotypic differences.
Moreover, these are not
just some random genes,
but in fact when we do ontology annotation
for these biased genes,
we see that they're
associated with development
and malformation of various
craniofacial structures,
including those structures that
are actually quite divergent
between human and chimp.
But now, a important question to ask is,
where do these interspecies differences
in enhancer signatures come from?
Are they due to differences
in the trans-regulatory environments
of the human and chimp neural crest?
So, different in
transcription factor networks,
things like that?
Or are they due to differences
in enhancer sequence itself?
So, cis-regulatory changes.
And to distinguish between
these two possibilities,
we designed the following assay.
We synthesized the library
of orthologous regions,
that were either
human-biased, chimp-biased,
or invariant in our epigenomic data.
And then we cloned this library
to a so-called self-transcribing
enhancer reporter vector
forming the basis of the STARR-seq,
as he described two years
backed by Alex Stark's lab,
and which relies on
the ability of enhancer
to activate its own
expression at a distance,
and then drive its own expression
and serve as its own barcode.
And we took this library and
introduced it to either chimp,
or human neural crest cells.
From this, we learned
two important things.
First of all, bias in epigenomic signature
translates into the bias and
ability of these sequences
to drive gene expression.
In other words, what we
predicted as human-biased,
which you should be seeing
here, was human-biased.
And what we predicted as chimp-biased,
was chimp-biased in general
in the ability to drive gene expression.
And the second important conclusion
was the direction of
the bias was the same,
whether we tested our
library in the context
of the human or chimp neural crest cells.
And what this tells us, is
that the bias is encoded
by the sequence of enhancers themselves,
rather than imposed by the differences
in trans-regulatory environments.
So if it's in the sequence,
and the trans-regulatory environments
are more conserved, we can go as far as
to the trans-regulatory
environment of the mouse,
to gain some insight where,
when and where during development
these enhancers may be active.
And here, I'm showing a
couple of examples of this,
where we're looking at
the human-biased enhancer,
and we're cloning orthologous sequence
from either human or chimp
to the LacZ enhancer reporter vector,
and testing in the context
of the mouse embryo.
And why there is a shared expression
in the olfactory placode,
there is a human-associated
gain in multiple,
in multiple domains
within the head and face.
And here is another example,
again, a human-biased enhancer.
This one is more pan-neural crest.
And again, you see the gain of activity
for the human sequence.
And this one is actually quite blazing in,
in the face, whereas the chimp,
corresponding chimp
sequence is not active.
So, this is interesting because it shows
that we can systematically
identify enhancers
that change the regulatory activity,
during recent human evolution,
and we can even learn something
about their spatial temporal
activity during development,
but what this type of
work will not tell us
is whether these enhancers
are actually responsible
for driving variation
in facial morphology.
And while we can model
some of these aspects
of variation in the mouse,
again mouse is not an ideal system
for studying human facial variation.
So to try addressing these questions,
we thought about harnessing glorious
normal-range human facial variation,
which you can see just
looking around this room,
and our ability to noninvasively
and quite precisely quantify it.
And to do this, we teamed up
with a group of
anthropologists, engineers,
and human geneticists,
who developed a very novel methodology
for unbiased facial phenotyping.
And, I just wanna mention
at least three names,
Peter Claes, Mark Shriver,
and Seth Weinberg.
And, what Peter has done is develop
this very precise method
to quantify facial shape,
which relies on 3D facial scans
that are then, mirror imaged,
and then remapped into the mesh,
dense mesh of 10,000 coordinates.
So essentially, in other words,
each face is translated
into 10,000 coordinates,
then averaged, to remove deviations
from bilateral symmetry,
and then aligned across many,
many participants in the study,
to establish correspondents
of these 10,000 coordinates.
And this allows for
unbiased facial phenotyping,
and quantifying shape variation
over global-to-local facial segments,
starting from very global
effects on facial variation,
to effects on very specific
aspects of the facial shape,
as highlighted here in yellow.
And this type of analysis has been done
on many, many participants,
over 2,000 participants,
and replicated on an independent cohort
of another 2,000 participants.
And, having genotype information
for this participant,
allowed us to perform genome
wide association studies
to identify candidate variants
that may be associated
with different aspects
of facial variation.
While I don't have time to go
into the details of that study,
I just wanna show you one example
that I think is really quite interesting.
So this example of one subgenetic variant
a lead SNP on Chr2
that will link to variation
in lower face morphology,
particularly the jaw shape.
So when we look at underneath this SNP,
at our epigenomic data,
we see that it falls smack in the middle
of an active neural crest enhancer.
But what is really interesting about it,
is that the same enhancer
is actually chimp-biased in activity.
Moreover, the very same SNP
was associated by another
group earlier this year,
with susceptibility to
nonsyndromic cleft lip and palate
in Europeans, as shown here.
So we're really quite excited
by examples like that,
because what this suggests
that perhaps overlapping
set of regulatory elements
can influence variation
in multiple levels,
both between the species,
within the species,
and then when combined
with either environmental
perturbation or other variants,
influencing disease susceptibility
in common disease like cleft lip palate.
So, we're starting to think that
it's going to be about the
quantitative differences
and about the combinatorial effect,
which really will ultimately
separate those three scenarios.
The differences between,
within species and disease states.
And with this thought, I wanna leave you,
and thank people involved,
in particular, Sara Prescott,
who now moved onto Harvard as a postdoc,
was extremely talented and
open-minded graduate student
who took on and started
all the evolutionary projects in my lab.
I wanna acknowledge Tomek
for most of the genomic data analysis
that I've shown you today
and really thinking about
how we can quantitatively
compare human and chimp epigenomic data.
I also grateful to Rusty
and Carol Marchetto,
about whom you already heard today,
for really sharing with us chimp IPS cells
very early in the game.
Our mouse genetics
collaborator, Licia Selleri,
and also our human
phenotyping and GWAS team,
Peter Claes, Seth
Weinberg, and Mark Shriver,
thank you very much.
(applause)
- So I thought I'd take
the director's prerogative
and spend the first five, 10
minutes going back in time
over some of the events that lead
to the work that I'm going to present.
And also because some of the people
that are here in the
audience were involved
in some of these early phenomena.
So first, let's step
back and go to the 1950s,
when the work of many
people have clearly shown
that we shared a common
ancestor with the great apes,
and most likely the chimpanzee,
but there's considered
to be this great gulf
that needed to be resolved,
but then Sarich and Wilson in the '60s,
by immunochemical techniques,
and Goodman, Russ Doolittle
here in the audience,
and others showed that most
of the proteins are identical.
Sequences are essentially identical,
and Mary-Claire King in her thesis work,
was asked to find something different,
and she couldn't find much at all.
And so, they wrote this famous paper
that said that maybe the
genes are nearly identical,
and the proteins are identical.
They just express differently.
And this theory actually held,
believe it not for almost 20 years,
although part of it is definitely true,
until Mary Olson, who's
also here in the audience,
suggested in 1999 that
gene loss may be important.
That it's getting rid of a
gene may be just as interesting
as having more of a
gene or changing a gene,
or its expression.
And by some coincidence
actually, that very year,
the end of that year, just before that,
we reported the first genomic
and biochemical difference
between humans and great apes,
the first known at the time.
And, it was due to gene loss, CMAH.
I'll come back to what CMAH is.
So let's define some of
the title words here.
Hominin, hominins are human ancestors
and our extinct evolutionary relatives,
that is Neanderthals example.
Hominids are human
ancestors that are living
and extinct evolutionary relatives,
which includes the great apes.
So we go back to our diagram here,
there are the hominids,
and there are the hominins.
And we are one of a group of hominins.
So, we go back into detail background.
Oh, before any of the
aficionados get upset,
the branching relationships here only,
do not reflect timing.
The branch length does not,
it's just relationships.
And there is one time
point that does matter,
and that's the one shown
down there 0.5 million years.
Right here is 0.5 million years,
the junction where the common ancestor,
Neanderthals, Denisovans, and Humans.
So, let's look at what
happened going up to there,
and this is a very complex slide.
But it includes all the known information,
except for the last couple
of years from Wood and Boyle,
talking about all the different hominins
that existed in Africa until
about two million years ago,
when the genus Homo emerged
and not only stayed behind in Africa,
and spread across Africa,
but spread all across the Old World.
And eventually, gave rise
to us again in Africa.
And, Homo of course had the wanderlust,
and wandered all over the Old World,
never crossed the waterway,
couldn't see the other
side, as far as we know,
but otherwise you've heard of Peking Man,
Java Man, and so on.
And then, this probably went
on for about two million years,
and finally our own species,
again the numbers have changed.
They change every month now,
because of the new data coming in,
but the general pattern is true.
Emerged in Africa, and
spread all across the world,
essentially replacing
all the other species,
including the species in Africa
that limited interbreeding.
So we had found a pseudogenization,
a gene deletion in humans,
and this has to do with sialic acid,
another word in my title.
So what's a sialic acid?
All cells in nature, without exception,
are coated with a dense array
of glycans, or sugar chains.
Here's a classic slide
from a Nobel laureate,
George Palade, in the early days of EM,
but he already saw the stuff
sitting on the surface.
But if you look over
here, at a mammalian cell,
you can see this huge,
thick layer of sugars.
Same in the bacterium,
and even many viruses
are coated with sugars
of this massive layers of glycans,
which is sort of the dark matter
of the biological universe
that most people don't study,
or even acknowledge
their existence in many.
You didn't see it in any of the
slides in the first session.
(laughter)
So these, on the outermost
strip of vertebrate glycans
are these sugars called sialic acids,
which sit out at the tip,
and there's a lot of them.
There can be millions and 10s,
and even hundreds of
millions of copies per cell.
A recent calculation
said that a lymphocyte
had a density of 100
millimolar on the surface.
That's right, millimolar, that's a lot.
And so, obviously they must
have a lot of biological roles.
And the story that we have
been pursuing is that,
the fact that there are
many kinds of sialic acids.
And the two most common ones are called
Neu5Ac and Neu5Gc.
(audience laughs)
Yes, we have some rock
and rollers in my group.
Gc is derived from Ac by
adding one oxygen atom
by this enzyme called CMAH.
And so, here is that single oxygen atom.
Now you may think that's trivial,
but that's a single oxygen atom added
to a 100 millimolar concentration
of something on the cell
surface, so that's a big effect.
And what we basically found
was that Gc was missing
in humans due to a mutation in CMAH.
Looking further into this
with Toshiyuki Hayakawa,
Yoko Satta, and Naoyuki Takahata.
We found, Pascal and
I found that there was
this Alu-mediated inactivation
that occurred in this manner,
taking out this critical exon
that was fixed in all humans.
All of you have this mutation, homozygous.
And this exercise was also useful
because this allowed timing
by several different methods,
none of which are perfect,
but I wouldn't go into
the details of the timing,
but all of them gave a time of about
2.5 to 3.5 million years where
the mutation first occurred.
So, we went further then
and collaborated with both
Svante Paabo and Meave
Leakey back at that time,
looking at fossil samples
and the sort of site fracture
into the DNA extraction,
and we could find only Ac
in Neanderthal fossils.
So we thought that maybe
there was no GSR sequence at the time.
Also, we're missing CMAH,
but then the question came up,
how did this mutation get fixed?
And, Pascal came up with
a very interesting idea.
After all, when you get a mutation,
if there is this mutation that is due to,
let's say a pathogen that is binding Gc,
leaving some people with Gc negative,
you'd expect a kind of a polymorphism
like you see in sickle cell disease.
How did it get fixed?
By the time we had knockout
mice with the same mutation,
which have a lot of
phenotypes, by the way,
that I'm not going to go
into human-like phenotypes.
And so, we could do this
experiment that he suggested,
which was to show
that while the rare male
that is Gc negative,
and if there's a large number
of males that are Gc positive,
the Gc positive sperm
are killed by antibodies
produced by the female.
In fact, human serum will
kill chimpanzee sperm, also.
And so, Steve Springer
actually did a calculations,
saying that within 30 to 650 generations,
this could actually generate two lineages.
And so we hazard a guess at this point,
be the origin of the genus Homo.
And, unfortunately sialic acids and DNA
do not survive in African fossils.
The samples that Meave Leakey gave us
had no sialic acids in them.
But very recently, this
is hot off the press,
we found that these N-glycolyl groups,
these Gc groups actually
survive in a byproduct
called chondroitin sulfate
in ancient fossils.
And in fact, Meave sent us some samples
from a four million year old bovid fossil,
and you could find GCCS there.
So, we now wonder whether we
can go back to this theory,
and we're trying to improve our techniques
and convince people to share with us
small amounts of their hominin samples,
but if you can do that,
we could end up with
N-glycolyl-CS positive and
N-glycolyl-CS negative fossils.
And this branch would then try to break up
this big bush that
everybody's studying right now
and get some lineage out of it.
Okay, what's a Siglec?
A Siglec is a molecule,
a family of molecules
that we discovered and
named some years ago,
which, through this red domain
on the amino terminal end,
this is the cell membrane,
binds sialic acid.
They have many functions, but
one of their major functions
is this subgroup called
CD33-related Siglecs.
What they basically do is see sialic acid
as self-associated molecular patterns.
You hear about danger-associated,
pathogen-associated molecular patterns.
Well why don't your cells attack you?
Well the reason is, they see
sialic acid and say, halt.
So the immune cell is stopped by that.
So you can think of it as
brakes on immune cells.
And so, these molecule patterns
are actually widespread.
Pascal suggested I show this picture,
'cause a picture speaks a thousand words.
Here's a fresh blood smear,
that's glyco-foreign on the surface,
covered with sialic
acids, red blood cells.
Here's a white blood cell, a neutrophil,
and you can see all the
Siglec-9 is clustered.
The red cells are holding
onto the neutrophil saying,
wait there, buddy, you're
not ready to fight yet.
And so of course, pathogens
have taken advantage of this.
And it turns out that
no pathogen can make Gc.
How have we lost Gc?
We threw away our best self-signal.
And so, now we have these bugs
of wolves in sheep's clothing
that are invading us.
(laughter)
And so, then we found a second mutation
affecting sialic acid biology in SIGLEC12.
And here, we had fixed genomic changes,
polymorphic genomic changes,
and major expression changes.
Well, three of the major categories,
but we were really quite
frustrated because without,
the level of molecular
biology we could do,
we couldn't go much further.
But fortunately, many people
started getting interested
in the chimpanzee genome.
This is an article I wrote.
And the baby, Papot,
from this photograph by Pascal Gagneux,
and Sarah Varki from Hudson Freeze.
I did get permission from Sarah Varki.
(laughter)
And so, Maynard got excited about this,
and actually 9-11 has
something to do with it,
but that's a story for another time.
And white papers are submitted,
we actually had the first
ever CARTA Symposium,
just before the chimpanzee
genome came out.
That's Sarah again, again,
with her permission.
So now we have the sequence
of chimpanzee genome,
and fast forward now 10, 12 years,
and we could look at all these SIGLECS.
The long and the short of it is
in the circle of life
that Pascal drew for me.
We find rows of SIGLECS,
mutations of SIGLECS
involving many, many different
parts of the circle of life.
From cells ranging from
sperm to gut epithelia
to T and B cells, to
even pancreatic islets,
and ROS production, and so on.
The problem was that we had,
just one or two genomes
of each of the apes.
And there's always this worry,
is it just genome quality?
Is this just chance, is
just ascertainment bias?
Are we like the prodigal drunk,
looking under the lamppost for the keys?
Fortunately, at that time, Evan Eichler
and Tomas Marques-Bonet came up
with great ape genetic diversity
and population history,
actually involving many
people and CARTA, as well.
So we had access to ape genomes.
So, now we could get
a reasonable number of ape genomes,
not as many as humans, of course.
But, still something to work with.
We did that, it turned out that,
in fact, even some of the polymorphisms
we thought were fixed
in apes were not fixed.
They're polymorphic, they're not fixed.
So, in fact we've seen
that apes don't have many mutations.
so this finding over here,
and some of these are,
of course are expression
patterns, is significant.
And so this, and so
we've shown you multiple
genomic events altering
hominin sialic acid biology,
and now I'll come to
the actual topic of the,
about the common ancestor
of humans and Neanderthals.
These mutations are all
found in African populations,
so they've predated the common
origin of modern humans.
Actually, a paper just online,
including Tony Capra, I think is here,
shows that genes involved
in sialic acid biology
do not harbor, at least strong signatures
of recent positive selection.
They're of more ancient origin.
And so, Stephane and Kay, from Leipzig,
showed a new method.
And showed in fact, there's no evidence
of strong selection on these genes
after the divergence of humans
and Neanderthal common ancestors.
So now we can zoom in here
and start looking at the wonderful data
that Svante Paabo and so
many others have generated
on Neanderthal and Denisovan genomes.
And, looking at these
sequences, we find that,
we can find essentially
all of these mutations,
almost all of them, although obviously
the population sizes here are very small.
So we can't, we don't know
whether they're fixed or not.
But you can find mutations
SIGLEC3, 12, 14, 16,
13, 17, SIGLEC12, CMAH.
There's a few other genes
that we're looking at.
And as for these
expression pattern changes,
we've looked at comparisons
with chimps, and bonobos, and so on,
but we don't have all
the possible comparisons.
But something seems to be going on
where a large number of genes
seem to have been turned on
in the human lineage in many tissues.
So, what we believe is that
this cluster of genes on chromosome 19
has undergone some changes.
Clearly undergone a
lot of genomic changes,
and perhaps secondarily,
perhaps affecting epigenetics,
and transcription, and so on,
also, produced a lot of
ectopic expression we think,
of SIGLECS in various other tissues,
but there's a lot more work to be done
before we can say much about that.
but in terms of what we think happened,
you can never be sure in evolution.
You just make up stories
and see if they fit.
It's more like a murder mystery
and actually a patient in
coma in emergency room,
the kind of thing I'm more
used to doing actually,
but we think that the CMAH mutation
really occurred two to
three million years ago,
and we have some other
connections to the genus Homo
that we haven't published yet,
or perhaps there was some incident,
or incidents involving loss of CMAH
and selection of the
kind that we suggested,
and perhaps pathogens.
And it turns out that the
binding pockets of the SIGLECS,
I am not showing you the data,
have evolved very rapidly, as well.
And so maybe there was selection there.
So, conclusions,
multiple genomic events
altering hominin sialic acid
and Siglec biology,
and there's a few other
sialic acid changes
I've not mentioned,
predate the common ancestor
of humans and Neanderthals.
Actually, I don't know of any other system
where they've been so many changes.
There are likely multiple selection forces
affecting innate immunity and
host-pathogen interactions.
And perhaps, this is the interesting part,
the secondary consequence has been
human-specific expression of CD33 Siglecs
in unusual cell types and tissues,
including brain microglia,
mucosal surfaces,
losses from some surfaces,
the reproductive system,
amnion, placenta, et cetera.
So, I'll leave it there,
and say that we have a lot of work to do.
I encourage others interested in this area
to join us in this pursuit, thank you.
(applause)
- My lab is primarily interested in
understanding some of the
molecular and cellular basis
for the development of the cortex,
but unlike some of the previous
speakers we're focusing
on the development of
neuronal connectivity
and how circuits assemble basically,
in developing brain.
I'm gonna move fast on the introduction,
'cause I think you've heard a
lot about the general interest
of understanding what makes us human,
and in particular, what makes
our brain human-specific.
Another way to phrase that
question as you heard before,
is to ask what happened to our genome
since we diverged from
our common ancestor,
more than 7, 10 million years.
There's actually debate
about that exact time
for divergence from our common ancestor.
So to the first question,
what makes our brain human-specific?
You have heard a lot today
about the possibility
that what makes our brain different
from our most common living relatives,
like chimps and bonobos,
or to other higher mammals,
would be brain size, or at
least the size of the cortex
relative to the rest of the brain.
I would argue that despite the fact that
that's the question that most
people are interested in,
it cannot be the entire
answer, for simple reason,
which is that if you look
at brain size expansion,
including the increases
in neocortical size,
many mammals have succeeded at this
without any real gain in
cognitive abilities, right?
In fact, brain size is best
correlated to body size,
not to cognitive abilities, right?
So, brain size and neocortex expansion
were probably an important
step during evolution,
and it happened many times
during mammalian evolution,
but it can't be the only explanation
for what makes our brain human-specific,
at least in emergence
of cognitive abilities.
So, you know many open
remaining possibilities.
Neuronal composition, right?
The type of neurons that are produced
that Rick and others have
talked about earlier.
Circuit connectivity, the
total number of synapses
made between neurons
are things that will
influence circuit function
and probably cognitive abilities.
Something that very few
people have talked about,
nonneuronal cells, astrocytes, microglia.
Those could, there's actually
some very recent evidence
suggesting that differences in composition
or total number of nonneuronal
cells might be difference
between human and non human primates.
So, today I'm gonna try to convince you
that we have evidence,
probably the first evidence,
suggesting that a specific
gene duplication event
has pretty significantly changed
both the number of synapses
made between neurons,
and we think actually affects
circuit connectivity and circuit function.
So, how did we get
interested in this question?
We got interested in this question
based on the work of several groups,
including beautiful work from Evan Eichler
that you'll hear about just after me,
so I'm not gonna bore you with details
about what Evan has did.
But, back in early 2000s,
work from Jim Sikela,
and then refined and expanded by Evan,
identified gene duplication events
that are specific to the human lineage,
gene duplications, new gene
copies, that are not present
in any other nonhuman primates
or in any other mammals.
So essentially, what
Evan has done has shown,
shown here on this graph,
so what Evan has shown is that in humans,
you have a whole list
of gene, about 30 genes,
that have extra copies essentially.
So those copies are specific to humans,
they're not found in nonhuman primates.
And unfortunately, or fortunately for us,
most of those genes have
completely unknown function.
That's not entirely true,
there is one gene in at least SMN1,
which is the gene that's mutated
in spinal muscular atrophy.
Turns out that humans, and humans only,
have an extra copy of
this, and it's actually
absolutely fascinating work
that's been done on this.
There's a drug treatment that
just emerged very recently,
actually taking advantage
of the second copy,
the human specific copy of SMN1.
If you're interested, I
can tell you more about,
but for vast majority,
all the other genes have
largely unknown function.
And so, except that around the time
when this first work was published,
there was one gene in that
list, SRGAP2 listed here,
that we were probably the only lab
working on this gene at that time.
And we had some interesting data
suggesting that this gene was actually
playing important functions
during brain development,
at least the ancestral copy of this gene,
but when Jim Sikela and Evan Eichler
published these results,
we were struck by the fact
that there are human-specific
copies of this gene.
And so, we embarked on
trying to characterize what
those human-specific
duplications of SRGAP2 do.
So as a paradigm, basically
many question arise
from this observation that
there are human-specific
gene duplicates from those.
The first one is which of those genes
are expressed in the human brain?
The second question is
what is the function
of the ancestral copy of this gene?
As I mentioned, most of
those genes have completely
unknown function during brain development,
so we had to start with this.
And the third question,
that's truly interesting,
is the function of the
human-specific paralogs
related to the function
of the ancestral copy,
or are those new copies
basically acquiring
some completely independent functions?
Some completely new functions,
independent of the function
of the ancestral copy, right?
Both scenarios could be true.
So, I'm gonna summarize here,
essentially 11 years of work from our lab,
from multiple people in my lab,
and then during the rest of the talk,
I'm gonna unpack and tell you a bit more
about how we got to those conclusions.
So essentially, SRGAP2A
is an adaptor protein
containing three functional domains.
This have bottom end
which is essentially a
homodimerization motif,
a central domain called
the Rap-GAP domain.
It's a domain that inactivates
a small GTPase called Rac-1.
And then there's SH3 domain,
that's essentially a protein
protein interaction motif.
So, all mammals, from
rodents to nonhuman primates,
and humans have this gene.
It's expressed, it's highly
expressed in the brain.
It's expressed largely in only neurons,
and also I'll show you later on,
it's actually very enriched at synapses.
But it turns out that about
two to four million years ago,
two gene duplication events at least
made this new copy that's
human specific emerge,
that we had to call SRGAP2C,
nd Evan will probably tell
you a bit more about that.
And so, this coding sequence
is truncated actually.
It doesn't express the full
length protein, it's truncated.
It expresses 90 percent
of this bottom end,
which remains able to bind
to the ancestral copy,
and largely inhibits it function, okay?
So, its main function, so it turns out
that we get essentially the same phenotype
when we inactivate SRGAP2A,
or when we induce the
expression of this gene, okay?
And, the phenotypes we get
are delayed, excitatory,
and inhibitory synaptic maturation,
this phenomenon called neoteny,
which is essentially defined by retention
of immature features for
longer periods of time
during development.
We get increased density
of both excitatory and
inhibitory synapses.
And finally, we get increased
cortical connectivity.
This is largely unpublished.
I won't, I probably won't have time
to tell you much about this.
So, how did we reach these conclusions?
So, the first that we did
a long time ago, in 2009,
we published expression
pattern for SRGAP2.
And this very simple
observation that the protein
in mouse cortex is expressed,
actually peaks at P1,
but is expressed largely
at postnatal time when,
between, during the first
two weeks of postnatal life
when the animals are basically
forming a lot of synapses.
And so, when this very talented post-doc,
Cecile Charrier, joined the lab,
she discovered that in fact,
SRGAP2 protein is very
enriched at synapses.
This is high resolution images
of individual synapses in mouse neurons.
And I hope you can
appreciate the fact that,
essentially there is very
little SRGAP2 in small synapses
and lots of SRGAP2
protein in large synapses.
Those synapses here are visualized.
Those excitatory synapses are visualized
by this protein, Homer1.
And it turns out that, at
that time we didn't know,
but in fact those two
proteins in function interact.
So, what is SRGAP2 function
in synaptic development?
So, neurons are absolutely amazing cells,
if you think about it, right?
Those cells are gigantic.
A fibroblast, that people
have talked about before,
would be the size of this
size body here, right?
So they're gigantic cells.
And, a graduate student in
the lab, Daniel Lascone,
has developed some new
methodology to actually,
at single-cell resolution in vivo,
visualize the presence and the topography
of all synapses, excitatory
and inhibitory synapses,
made into a single neuron, okay?
And so this allows us to understand both,
to have very quantitative ideas
of where synapses are
localized in neurons,
how many they form.
And you know, for a
typical neuron like this,
this layer, two, three
pyramidal neurons in a mouse
forms somewhere between four
and 6,000 excitatory synapses
and somewhere between 1,000
and 1500 inhibitory synapses.
Right, so staggering numbers
for just a single cell, right?
And so, if you zoom up on those green dots
that you see here,
those are individual
spines, dendritic spines.
I'm gonna talk a lot about
those in the rest of the talk.
Those protrusions, those micron,
this is a, the scale is one micron here,
so they're tiny protrusions,
essentially constitutes
individual synapses.
If you look at an EM pictures
of a single spine like this,
these protrusions, this is the site,
basically a single spine
constitutes a single synapse.
It's the postsynaptic receiving end,
basically, of a synapse.
So this is an axon,
with those neurotransmitter
filled vesicles here,
that release neurotransmitter
in the synaptic cleft,
that then activate the
postsynaptic receptors here.
So essentially, those
synapses are the basis
for neuronal communications, right?
And, decades of work by hundreds of labs
have identified essentially
a zoo of proteins,
hundreds of proteins that are localized
pre and post-synaptically
here at the dendritic spines.
Those proteins, the main
job of those proteins,
including these Homo
Shank-interacting proteins
that I'm gonna tell you in a second,
is to basically create
a very complex scaffold
to anchor and stabilize
the neurotransmitter receptors here
that sends neurotransmitter release here.
And so, we discovered that SRGAP2
is actually directly
reacting with Homer here.
And in fact, I'll show you later on,
SRGAP2 seems to control
the scaffolding properties
of those proteins and controls
the rate of accumulation
of those neurotransmitter receptors,
such as AMPA receptors during development.
So how did we discover this?
Takayuki Sassa, the first post doc
who was involved in this project,
started by making a knockout for SRGAP2A
for the ancestral copy in mice.
So, we made this knockout in order
to ask what happens when
we delete this gene.
And the main thing that happens
when you delete this
gene is essentially that,
if you look at those spines.
The size of the spines,
I forgot to mention,
is proportional to how mature it is,
how many postsynaptic receptors
have accumulated there.
If you look at an animal
three weeks after birth,
a wild type animal.
Those spines are already mature,
so they have mature synapses.
There's a lot of data
has, that has shown this.
But then if you look at the heterozygous,
so if you delete one copy
or two copies of the gene,
you have significantly smaller spines
at this juvenile time point.
They have longer necks,
so the neck that connects this spine head
to the dendrites is longer.
And most interestingly,
there's a pretty significant increase
in density of the spines,
but interestingly enough,
this size effect is transient.
So if you look at P65,
about 40 days later,
those spines reach maturation.
So, it's just a delay in maturation.
Those spines, when you inactivate SRGAP2
seems to be much slower
at reaching maturations.
Instead of being mature at
P21, they're mature at P45.
But in the adult basically,
the spines remain having a longer neck
and very significantly higher numbers,
basically a significantly higher density.
So, what happens if we
humanize mouse neurons
for SRGAP2C, right?
I briefly mentioned before that our model
based on studies we published before,
was that the truncated version,
the human-specific version of this gene,
would bind to and inhibit
the function of the ancestral copy, right?
So the prediction would be,
that if we express SRGAP2C
in the mouse genome
that expresses SRGAP2A,
we would get phenotype that
look exactly like this,
and that's exactly what we found.
Essentially, if you look at
juvenile animals control,
or SRGAP2C humanized mouse neurons,
you get this delayed maturation, right,
but they actually reach
maturation at P65 instead of P21,
and they retain longer necks
and higher spine density.
So this was a very interesting
result for us, right?
This says, because essentially
we know that those three features,
delayed maturation, longer neck,
which actually has very
important function,
and higher density are three
phenotypes that are known
to characterize human neurons
compared to either mouse
neurons or nonhuman primates.
So, beautiful work from Javier DeFelipe,
Raphe Yuste, my colleague at Columbia,
have shown that if you look
at spine density for example,
between human or nonhuman primates,
or if you look at spine density
between human and mouse neurons,
you essentially get 30
to 50 percent more dense,
higher density of spines,
and those spines have longer necks.
And we also know that synaptic development
in humans is profoundly neotenic.
So basically, very prolonged maturation,
very delayed maturation.
So, this is interesting, right?
Essentially with just
introducing a single gene
that's human-specific in mouse neurons,
we phenocopy three major aspects
of synaptic development,
delayed maturation, higher density,
and changing the morphology
of those spines, right?
But we have a problem,
which is that we know that changing
and increasing the density
of excitatory synapses
cannot be the only explanation,
since beautiful work from
Javier Defelipe and many others,
have shown that there's an amazing degree
of conservation in the
ratio between excitatory
and inhibitory synapses
in the cortex, right?
So we know that, if that's the
only thing SRGAP2 is doing,
increasing the number
of excitatory synapses,
we would have a problem.
We would have major imbalance
between excitation and
inhibition, which is a landmark
of many neurodevelopmental
disorders, for example,
such as autism or epilepsy.
So, either SRGAP2 was doing the job
and was coordinating the maturation
of both excitatory and
inhibitory synapses,
or some other genes,
maybe some of the other gene duplications
that I mentioned before, would do the job.
It turns out that nature
has selected SRGAP2,
probably for a reason.
It's because SRGAP2 does
exactly the same thing
it does at excitatory synapses
at inhibitory synapses.
So we discovered this
because, more recently,
because now we can actually
visualize inhibitory synapses
with amazing accuracy using,
for example, this gefyrin-GFP.
Gefyrin is a protein that's
exclusively localized
at inhibitory synapses.
And using single cell technology,
single cell genetic labeling technology,
we can not only visualize,
with some micron precision, spines,
we can actually localize
those inhibitory buttons,
even the ones that are made
on dendrite shaft here,
or even more rare buttons
that are made directly
on spine heads, here.
I can tell you more about this later on.
And remarkably, we find
that the same thing happens.
Then for spines, if you
look at inhibitory button,
if you down regulate this
SRGAP2A, the ancestral copy,
or if you introduce and
humanize mouse neurons
for a SRGAP2C expression,
you get higher density
of inhibitory clusters.
Those inhibitory synapses
are much smaller early on,
but ultimately reach maturation at P65.
And, there's a change in
their actual localizations,
a striking increase in the ones,
the inhibitory synapses made
onto the spine heads here.
So, increased density
and delayed maturation,
it's pretty remarkable.
In fact, if you plot the
normalized increase in density
for spines and for inhibitory synapses
between control and
humanized mouse neurons,
we get remarkably similar effects, right?
So the conclusion here is that nature
has selected a gene duplication event,
that of a gene that essentially controls
the coevolution of inhibitory
and excitatory synapses.
This is really, I think, a very important
take-home message right here.
So, I will finish here by taking a minute
to recap everything I've told you today.
We've identified a gene, SRGAP2A,
which in its ancestral form
expressed in all mammals,
controls three very important
aspects of synaptic development.
It controls the density of excitatory
and inhibitory synapses.
Through work I didn't
have time to show you,
we're actually able to do
structure function analysis
in vivo using gene replacement strategies.
And so, we can actually
dissociate how SRGAP2
regulates spine density and
inhibitory synapse density,
from how it controls the maturation
of excitatory or inhibitory synapses.
And we discovered,
that the human-specific copy of this gene,
which is this truncated form,
which remains able to
bind to the ancestral copy
and inhibits its function,
inhibits all three major
functions of SRGAP2, right?
So what are the future
directions on this project?
So, there are three future directions.
The first one is, what are the
upstream regulators of these proteins?
I didn't tell you anything
about how this gene is regulated
and how the protein itself is regulated.
We have some evidence of
what's upstream of this.
The second, very important question,
is where is this increased
number of connections coming from, right?
This gene basically,
the emergence of this human-specific copy
increases the total number of synapses
by 30 or 40 percent,
which is very significant.
Where are those connections
coming from, right?
We have some ideas about this already.
And finally, probably the most important,
is what aspect of circuit
function has been affected
by the emergence of this
human-specific copy?
That's something that's much
more difficult to approach,
but believe it or not, we actually have
some very interesting
new results about this.
So finally, the people who did the work.
The work was largely carried out
by a very talented postdoc
in my lab, Cecile Charrier,
who now has her own lab
at Ecole Normale Superieure
in Paris, in France,
but she was assisted by many people
and many people in my lab,
at least there's four people listed here
are involved in current
aspect of the project.
And finally, I'm excited
since I moved to Columbia
about four years ago,
Columbia's creating a
third campus actually,
called Manhattenville.
And very recently, we went
from an architectural sketch,
to an actual building
that will host 55 labs,
about 1,000 people.
So, this will become a mind,
brain, and behavior institute.
We are very excited to
move into this building,
hopefully this fall.
Thank you for your attention.
(applause)
(upbeat music)